DAN SANDERSON: All right.
Let's get started.
It is 1:40.
This is "Building
developers.google.com on
Google App Engine." This
is an App Engine talk.
Make sure you're in
the right place.
I'm Dan Sanderson.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google.
I've been at Google for about
six and a half years.
I worked on the App Engine team
for a few years, from
2008 to 2011.
And since 2011, I've been
working on the Google
Developers website.
That's developers.google.com.
How many of you have seen the
Google Developers website?
Excellent.
I thought so.
I've also written this book,
"Programming Google App
Engine," published by O'Reilly,
currently in its
second edition.
The second edition came
out last October.
I hope you get a chance to
take a look at that.
I want to talk about Google
Developers today.
The Google Developers website is
an App Engine application.
It's written in Python.
In the last two years, from 2011
to today, we've built out
a website with a bunch of
different features.
We have a content management
system that hosts all the
technical documentation
that's on the website.
We have an events calendar, the
developer showcase, the
Google Developer Groups
homepages, Google Developers
Live, with all the live
streaming video, and of
course, the Google
I/O website.
I want to talk about
how we built this
website on App Engine.
But I want it to get
pretty specific.
I want to talk about the
App Engine details.
And so I'm going to
focus on a very
specific part of the website.
We're going to talk about just
a piece of the content
management system.
Of course, content management
has a bunch of
different parts to it--
the static content build,
publishing workflows, that
sort of thing.
But I want to talk about kind
of the App-Engine-specific
parts of that.
So we're going to just take
a part of that and
talk about it today.
The design that I want to talk
about is the design we
actually use.
It's a pretty straightforward
design pattern you've probably
seen before.
And we'll talk about
how that gets
implemented on App Engine.
And I'm going to focus on the
App Engine-y bits with regards
to the implementation so we
don't get distracted by other
parts of it.
If you have any questions about
anything that I haven't
talked about, feel free to
find me later, and we
can talk about it.
I'm happy to talk about
the implementation.
We'll also talk about how this
is implemented, what tools we
use, what libraries we use.
And here, I'm a little
bit conflicted.
We have been working on this
website for a couple of years.
And App Engine has changed
quite a bit in
the last two years.
There are quite a few new tools,
libraries, and services
that have changed some of the
best practices on how you
actually build these things
with App Engine.
So many of the things we
actually do with real code are
a little bit out of date in
terms of best practices.
I would love to just show
you the real thing,
the real-world code--
it's messy.
It's long.
But it's also been tested
and runs the real thing.
But I think I would be doing
a disservice if I didn't
acknowledge the new libraries
and tools
that have been developed.
So we're going to take a hybrid
approach with this talk.
And we're going to take the
design I actually use, but
we'll use a modern
implementation.
We'll talk about how to build
it with the modern stuff.
We'll use examples in Python.
And I'll try to call out
discrepancies between the real
implementation and what I'm
talking about as I have time.
Again, if you have questions--
more about like what we actually
do and the sort of
hairy details--
just let me know.
And I'll try to call out
alternative designs as we can.
But we have a lot of material
to go through.
So I'm probably going to be
rushing through a lot of it.
So let's sketch out a content
management system just
to work with here.
We want the content managed
separately from other parts of
the website.
That's kind of what a content
management system means, is
that there's other stuff going
on on the website.
So this is software built
into the app.
And content publishers, content
developers, are going
to be interacting with the
software to get the content
onto the website.
This is going to be
a file-based CMS.
A lot of people, when they think
of CMS, they think of
editing text in text areas
in a web form.
For technical documentation,
we have content developers
that are editing lots of
different files with lots of
regular structure.
And so they're going to be using
local files for that and
then uploading them to the
website using a client tool.
So there's going to be a
client-server interaction in
this design.
Content developers are making a
lot of changes all at once.
Basically, they're
developing--
writing the content for a new
release of a new feature, and
then they want all of
it to go up at once.
They have a lot of changes to
represent, potentially over
many files, possibly hundreds
or even thousands of files.
We don't want just anyone
publishing to our website.
So of course, we have access
controls for this
client-server interaction.
When we think about the design,
we're going to try to
accommodate fast file serving.
Obviously, that's
just a general
requirement that we want.
But we're going to need to think
about that when we do
our data modeling and
things like that.
Most importantly, the usage
model here is we have many
content developers working on
different parts of the website
concurrently.
So we're going to need to
accommodate that as we work
through this.
So if we just imagine a client
of some kind, let's say a
command line tool that's
passed a set of files.
I've got my files on my desktop,
and I want to get
them to the website.
So let's just start with here.
I've got a Publish command.
And I want this Publish command
to get these files
onto the website.
Well, we've got a client-server
interaction.
Why don't we just do this?
The client tool uploads the
files to the server.
It could do it one at a time.
It can call an upload endpoint
on the server.
And then the server takes those
things and puts them on
the website.
The payload would just be a URL
path and a content type
and the data block.
And then the server installs
it so that when people come
and ask for that URL path, they
serve that data with that
content type.
I'll wave my hand over the part
where the client figures
out what the URL path and
the content type are.
You can imagine different
ways of doing that.
Internally, we just use
directory structure
conventions for that in our
revision control repository to
figure out what the
content root is.
So this is great, actually.
This gets us most of what
we want, right?
We can get files onto
the website.
We can create new paths.
We can update existing paths.
Now, usually with data, you
want to do a third thing.
You've got Create.
You've got Update.
And of course, we are going to
want to be able to delete
paths as well.
You can imagine that maybe the
client can just issue Delete
commands in addition
to Upload commands.
But that would require that
the client has to maintain
some kind of internal notion
of what is on the server.
It has to know what to delete
in order to do that.
And that's a lot of work and
can get kind of messy.
So the client knows
what it has.
The server knows what it has.
Why don't we just make the
server do the work?
So the client just needs to
say, this is what I have.
Do what is necessary.
And so we'll just add a new
request in here, a new call.
It's a Start call.
It says, OK, this
is what I have.
Please do what you need to do.
And also, these are the
files I'm uploading.
So this is the client's
opportunity to say that.
And then the server can turn
around and figure out what it
needs to do.
Now, each content developer is
working on a different part of
the website.
So they're probably not going
to have a complete view,
up-to-date view of the entire
website in their local files.
So it's not quite sufficient
to say, this is what I have
for the entire website.
Do what's necessary.
So we have a notion
of projects.
And in this case, projects
are just subpaths.
So if I'm a content developer
working on, say, the App
Engine documentation,
I've got local files
under slash App Engine.
And I have a complete up-to-date
view of what App
Engine Docs look like.
And that's what I
want to upload.
So our protocol, the Start
Request says, this is the
project that I'm working on.
These are the project roots.
And these are the files that I
have in this project root.
Please do the right thing.
Then the server says, oh, you've
got A, B, and D. Well,
I've got A, B, and C. So I guess
I should be deleting C
and you'll be giving me the
uploads for A, B, and D later.
So great.
We've got a way to synchronize
the state of the client onto
the server.
I'm not entirely happy with this
diagram, mostly because
the client's doing a lot
of the driving here.
It's trying to get everything
onto the website.
And of course, if the client
gets interrupted, there's
going to be a problem, or at
least a problem by our
definition.
We decided that as a requirement
for us, we don't
want this state where you can
leave the server in an
inconsistent state.
If the server is just going to
start doing stuff with the
live website, with the live
data, as the client is issuing
these requests, then if the
client gets interrupted, it
could get this inconsistent
state, this incomplete version
of the website.
So we don't want that.
What we want is a notion of
transactionality for these
publish events.
Either the publish event
happens or it doesn't.
That means we want either the
before state, which is if
anything goes wrong on either
the client side or the server
side, we want the website to
look like it did before,
before we did anything to it.
And then if it succeeds, it
should succeed completely.
All of the changes go up.
So to do that, the server needs
to know when the client
has finished a complete
description of what it's
talking about.
So we need one more
request in here.
And we'll call it Commit.
The client issues a
Start Request that
describes what it has.
It uploads all the files,
potentially hundreds of files.
And then at the end, it
says, OK, I'm done.
Do what you need to do.
And then the server, instead
of doing things live to the
live data all along the way,
it's just going to store these
things away.
It's going to store away a
change in description.
And it's going to store away the
things that get uploaded.
And then once the Commit comes
in, then the server knows that
it can start making changes
to the live website.
I'm going to make one minor
modification to this diagram.
I'm going to make it
look like this.
App Engine makes a distinction
between user requests, which
in this case, is requests
coming in from the
command-line tool, and
background tasks.
They're both executed in
your app instances.
They're both handled by Request
Handler-like things.
But user requests are expected
to return quickly.
And so they have a time
limit of 60 seconds.
Background tasks have
up to 10 minutes.
And of course, they can spawn
other background tasks and do
an arbitrary amount of work.
So most of the work we're going
to do, especially if
we're acting on thousands of
different files, thousands of
different datastore entries or
whatever you might want to be
doing, it's going
to take a while.
And so we need to do it
as background work.
One of the things to note here
is that each of these arrows
is an opportunity for
the server to
return an error code.
So if anything goes wrong-- if
there's a bad request, the
client made an invalid request,
or there's some kind
of inconsistency or there's a
transient error on the server
side-- the server can say just
bail, and say, look, client, I
don't know what to
do with this.
I'm bailing on this.
And then the client can then
report that error code to the
user, the content developer, and
see, oh, nothing is going
to happen on the website
because of this.
And I'm going to have to fix it
or wait for it to be fixed
or file a bug report
or whatever.
And so each of these is an
opportunity for the server to
return an error without having
any changes going live.
Nothing has changed the live
website until the very end.
But the other important thing
there is that the Commit
Request is the last opportunity
for the server to
return an error code.
So if it's going to kick off
some background work, it has
to be pretty sure that
that background
work is going to succeed.
Once the Commit is in, the
change is committed and the
client is just told, oh, OK,
the Commit is successful.
I don't have to worry
about it.
It will eventually go
live on the website.
So we need to accommodate
that as well.
So to summarize the publishing
protocol, we have a Start
Request that starts a change
with the change description.
We upload the files we need.
And we have a Commit Request
that says, OK,
this is what we need.
You might want an Abort
Request in there, too.
In our case, abort just
means clean up all
that stuff you stored.
It's not really going to impact
things to have an
uncommitted change just
sitting around.
It's just going to be
some extra data.
But it's a nice clean up.
And sometimes the client does
have the opportunity to issue
an Abort Request.
Of course, it doesn't always
have the opportunity to issue
an Abort Request.
It could be failing because
of a power outage or
a bug in the client.
That sometimes happens.
And so it's good to have a
scheduled task, a cron job,
that goes in and aborts
stale changes as well.
So we've got client-server
interaction.
We said we wanted it to
be authenticated.
Let's talk about that part.
There are a bunch of different
ways of doing authentication.
App Engine has had, for a long
time, server-side capabilities
to make it easy to implement
web services with OAuth for
authentication.
There's a new way,
though, that's--
I think really cool and
really important.
It makes it really easy to do
this very common thing of
setting up a web service
in different ways.
And it's called Google
Cloud Endpoints.
The difference between writing
your own and using Google
Cloud Endpoints is that you get
all of the features that
normally accompany any other
Google web service, using the
same infrastructure.
It can apply to your web
service, whatever it may be.
And you just set that up as an
App Engine application, and
you get all of that
infrastructure built into it.
So it's got server libraries
for the Python and Java
runtime libraries-- we're going
to use Python today--
and client libraries for
practically everything.
If you've called a Google web
service before, you've
probably use the client
libraries.
You've seen we have a dozen
or so of them in all these
different languages.
And you can use the very same
client libraries to make
authenticated requests to
your own web services.
So that's what we're
going to do today.
This makes it especially easy to
set up backends for mobile
applications, both
Android and iOS.
They have a full libraries and
documentation for making these
authenticated requests.
It makes it really easy.
And also for rich web
applications, if you've got a
rich JavaScript app that's
making requests
back to your server.
So those are especially easy
with the given documentation
and libraries.
We're going to be doing
something slightly different
but still entirely possible,
which is to use a command-line
tool to make the same kind of
authenticated requests.
And we're going to write
that in Python.
So I have a lot of slides here
on Endpoints just because it's
kind of the new thing.
I'm going to speed through
them really quickly.
Let me know later if
you have questions.
I have other things
I want to get to.
But basically, you're
setting up a server.
A service has methods.
And methods pass these messages
back and forth.
They get a request in
and a response out.
So you can just set up these
messages as ProtoRPCs in sort
of a general purpose way here.
You can see they're modeled--
if you've done any work with
ext.db or ndb for modeling data
in the datastore, this is
a similar kind of thing.
You're modeling these
messages.
And you get typed fields
and things like that.
In this case, the word
"start" here is
just our Start Request.
It's the name of our method.
And so I've got a StartRequest
and a StartResponse that we
pass in the project prefixes
and the upload paths.
And we get back a change ID,
which we can use in further
interaction with the server as
we go through the change
protocol for uploading
the change.
So messages can be defined
as ProtoRPCs.
I did want to call out here that
a really common thing to
do with these messages is either
a message is coming in
that describes a data structure
that you end up
storing in the datastore.
Or oftentimes, the user has made
a request for some data
in the datastore, and that's
coming back out in its
basically identical structure is
the way you're storing it.
So if you're doing that just
with ProtoRPCs, you've got
some redundant code in there.
You're describing the data
structure for the datastore.
And then you're describing
the exact same
thing in your message.
There's an open source library
called Endpoints Proto
Datastore that lets you just
take the ndb model and use
that as your message
structure.
So definitely look at that, if
that's what you're doing.
And you usually are.
I'm not going to use it in my
demo today, just because I'm
going to do something slightly
different in the way we create
the datastore entities.
But it's a really
useful library.
So here's the service.
Again, I won't go into
too much detail.
But you can see a service
is just a class.
It extends a service class.
We have a decorator that adds
some information about it.
We'll talk about client
IDs in a moment.
The service class has methods
that just represent the
methods of the service.
So here's how you do the Start
method of our service.
Again, we've got a decorator
describing the request and
response data structures.
And then the method
implementation just gets a
request object, builds
a response
object, and returns it.
Here is how we do
authorization.
So at this point, because we
haven't authenticated API--
and we'll talk more
about that.
But by this point on the server
code, we already know
who the user is.
So the user has authenticated
with the client.
The client has grabbed
credentials to act on the
user's behalf.
And now this message already
has the user information
associated with it.
So that's really easy to get out
of the library and start
doing this.
I'm comparing the email address
with a fixed list of
known content developers,
in this case.
You can get as fancy
as you want with
access control lists.
If there's an error, I just
raise an exception.
And this is one of the
exceptions that comes with the
Endpoints library.
Notice that when we modeled the
response message, we did
not even think about errors.
Errors are handled entirely
by the library.
So when you just raise one of
these exceptions, Endpoints
knows to set the HTTP status
code appropriately.
You can add arbitrary text
messages to that.
You can define your own
exception classes.
It's all built in.
And here's just an example of
building a response and
returning it.
To actually set this
up in the server,
we're going to create--
this is basically the
equivalent of a WSGI
application.
If you're using web app or
anything else in Python to set
up an app, you're going
to create the same
kind of thing here.
This is how you get that from
the Endpoints library.
And this is how you map it
into your app.yaml file.
The URL here has to
be exactly this.
It's underscore ah, slash
spi, slash dot star.
That's not a typo.
That's S-P-I. You'll see
AH API in a few places.
But here, it has to be SPI.
And that's just referring to
that app variable that we set
the module global.
OK, so client IDs--
every client uses an ID.
And not to be confused with
user IDs, of course.
This is the client ID.
We're going to have one
client, which is the
command-line tool.
The client has to identify
itself in order to act on
behalf of the user.
So the user signs in and gets
permission and so forth.
To get these client IDs, you
use the Google API Console,
again, just like with any
other Google API.
And so here's one way
to get to it--
developers.google.com/console.
Here's what it looks like.
I'm not going to go through
a full console demo.
But I will just really quickly
talk through the process.
You create a project.
Under API Access, you
create a client.
And when you do this, it'll give
you some options as to
which kind of client
you want to create.
All the clients are basically
the same.
It just sort of changes
the way the console
interacts with you.
And in this case, even though
it's a command-line tool,
we're going to create a web
application client.
It's a little bit confusing,
but we need that, because
we're going to edit the
settings, and we're going to
set the authorized redirect
URIs like so.
We do this because we want it
to interoperate with the
development server as we're
doing local development.
So this is an easy
way to do that.
Just add localhost 8080 and
localhost 8090 to the redirect
URIs, and that will get it
to work with your local
development server.
Don't forget to add your
actual website as well.
And so on the server side, we've
got those client IDs in
that annotation.
We're just going to set
that client ID.
That's the client ID that comes
out of the APIs Console
when you create it.
I've also added a second
client ID here.
This is for the API Explorer.
This is a feature of Endpoints
that it makes it really easy
to test your service without
writing any client code.
This is a built-in,
general-purpose client for
experimentation and
trying things out.
So you add this ID to the
list of clients that
the service is expecting.
And you can use this really
powerful tool.
And it's so powerful I want
to demonstrate it.
So here's the URL you
would normally use.
This is for a development
server.
It's _ah/api/explorer.
I've got a development server
running for a little service
right here.
Going to open a browser.
Go to localhost 8080,
API Explorer--
did I get that right?
This does require an internet
connection because it's
getting the API explorer
JavaScript
code from a live service.
But what it then does-- the
JavaScript then calls localhost.
You saw there were some
requests there.
And what it's actually
fetching is
the discovery document.
You might have seen discovery
documents in interacting with
Google APIs.
It's a machine-readable
description of the API that it
can fetch directly
from the service.
And so it knows from the
Endpoints annotations, the
decorations that we made to
the class and the methods,
that we have a Site
Publish API.
I can click on this.
And here are the methods.
I've got a Start, an Upload,
and a Commit.
I didn't implement Abort
in this case.
I'll click on Start.
And I get this cool little
request editor.
It already knows the structure
of the request fields.
And so I can just do this.
And let's add some
upload paths--
var, HTML, maybe add
one more, vaz.png.
And so we're creating a
change description.
This is calling the
Start method.
And I click Execute.
And you can see it's called
the service locally.
And it's sent it this request.
And I got back this response--
Not Authorized.
Because I have not authorized
this client to act on my
behalf when interacting
with the service.
So I go back-- you
can do that.
Go back up here.
Click this little switch.
And I say, yes, authorize
for these scopes.
And now it's going to make me
go through the sign-in flow.
It's opened up a little
browser window.
I'm going to sign in with
my Google account.
And I am using two-factor
authentication.
I hope you are, too.
Now it's signed in.
That little switch
has turned blue.
It's turned on.
Now I can click Execute.
And there's the request again.
And I get a response
with the change ID.
So it is now interacting on my
behalf with the service on the
local development server.
And these are screenshots in
case that didn't work.
All right.
So the client-- we're going
to use the Python Client.
This is where you go to get all
those cool client libraries.
I mentioned the discovery
document.
And for the command-line tool,
we're actually going to
generate the discovery document
locally and then just
have that discovery document
in a file, so the client
doesn't actually have to hit any
service to figure out what
service it's interacting with.
The client library is then
going to generate a
language-native API to the
client code based on that
discovery document.
And then the library, of course,
includes some extra
tools to make OAuth easy.
So we're going to see that.
So here's how you generate
a discovery document.
I won't talk about
too much detail.
This tool is included in
the App Engine SDK.
It's called Endpoints Config.
I do want to point out you're
probably going to want to make
two discovery documents-- one
for localhost and one for your
actual server.
And when you do that, there's
a little bit of a
sharp corner here.
You have to manually edit the
localhost version of the
discovery document to replace
HTTPS with HTTP.
That's how you get it to
work with localhost.
But that host name parameter
is how you can generate
different versions.
And so this is client
code now.
It's Python, but it's
client code.
We're loading the discovery
document.
And then we're just passing
it to the client API.
You get the service
object out of it.
To do the authentication, we
can do something like this.
What this is going to
do is it's going to
prompt me to sign in.
It'll go get credentials
from the service.
And then it's going to save
those credentials in a file.
And then subsequent runs of the
command-line tool, I'm not
going to have to
sign in again.
It's already authorized
to do that.
So I can use the tool multiple
times without having to sign
in over and over again.
I get this wrapped HTTP
object at the end.
And then when I actually call
the service, I just call the
start method, which is,
again, generated from
the discovery document.
That is my Start method.
Off the service object, I get
this request out of it.
And then I can execute
the request with our
wrapped HTTP object.
I get back a response.
And I can access the change
ID like that.
And so real quick for that.
Here's the server on the left
and my command over here.
Notice that when I ran the
command-line tool, it went
back to the browser.
This is how it prompts
me to sign in.
It is actually sending me
to Google to sign in.
You also notice that I've
already signed in, because
signed in to Google, for
the previous demo.
But I still need to authorize
this client
to act on my behalf.
So I am prompted to do that.
I click Allow Access.
And control returns back to
the command-line tool.
And it finishes what
it's doing.
And then it gets back
a change ID.
So now the command-line tool
is interacting on my behalf
with the service locally.
And the only change I need to
make there to use the live
service is to use a different
discovery document.
OK, so we have a change
description
getting to the service.
We have a way of communicating
with the service and doing the
Start, Upload, and
Commit calls.
Now we need to figure
out what to do next.
We need to store that change
in description somehow.
So let's store it in
the datastore.
The datastore is schema-less.
We're going to use the ndb
library to actually model this
data so it's got a consistent
structure.
And this is the structure
we're going to use.
Basically, we store our project
prefixes and our
upload paths.
And we have some extra fields.
We definitely want to record
who does what.
You're going to want to go
back and see who's made
changes to your website,
I'm very sure.
And then we're going to keep
track of whether this change
has been explicitly committed
or aborted.
One specific thing we want to
talk about with changes.
Later on, we're going to need
some way of ordering changes.
What we want is to promise to
the user the changes show up
on the website on a first come,
first served basis.
And so to do that, we need to
know who came first when these
changes have been created.
A couple ways you might try
to think to do that.
Maybe we use a datetime.
We generate the datetime that
it comes in as a field and
then we order by datetime.
That's probably not the best
idea if you really need strict
ordering, because the datetime
is actually set from the
system clock of the
app instance.
And different app instances
are going to
have different clocks.
There's going to be a clock
skew of as many as minutes
when you do it that way.
So you probably don't
want datetimes if
you want strict ordering.
Another option is to let the
datastore come up with a
system ID when you create
the change record.
It can do this.
If you don't set a key name,
it'll come up with its own
numeric ID.
These are generally
increasing IDs.
But especially if you've got two
entities that are not in
the same entity group, the
system IDs are not guaranteed
to be in monotonically
increasing order.
The different shards of the
datastore are going to have
different allocated ID ranges.
So it'll be guaranteed to assign
unique system IDs, but
not necessarily increasing
system IDs.
If they're in the same entity
group, you get something
closer to monotonically
increasing, but it's still not
guaranteed by the datastore.
So our idea here is to keep
track of our own change IDs.
We are going to store
the next change ID.
And then we're going to update
it whenever we create one of
these things.
Of course, we need to update
it transactionally.
And we're going to need to use
a transactional primitive of
the datastore in order to make
sure that two changes don't
get created with the
same change ID.
So there's going to be a
singleton datastore entity
holding the change ID
in the datastore.
This is a really nice
opportunity.
We do need a transaction here.
This would be a great use for a
feature that came out about
a year ago or so ago called
cross-group transactions.
Now, you might be familiar
with how datastore
transactions work.
Entities are created
in entity groups.
And a transaction can execute
over multiple entities, but
all those entities have to be
in the same entity group.
You have to know that ahead of
time as you're modeling your
data what is going to be
changed in the same
transaction.
And so this new feature allows
you to actually use up to five
entity groups in a single
transaction.
Now, in terms of scalability,
five isn't a much
different from one.
But the cool thing about
cross-group transactions is
they don't have to be the
same five every time.
You can actually decide which
entity groups are involved.
And the datastore will take a
little bit of extra time.
It's a little bit slower.
But it'll make sure it can
meet all its consistency
guarantees as it's making
changes of up to five entity
groups when it does that.
So you can have the change
ID in one entity group.
You can create new changes in
other entity groups and then
just sort of loop those two
together in a single
transaction as you're updating
these things.
And you get basically
the same effect.
But in our case, it's not going
to make that much of a
difference.
You do have to think about your
actual throughput needs
and how complicated these
things are going to be.
And in our case, we're talking
hundreds of content
developers, not hundreds
of thousands.
So we just said, OK, let's just
put everything in the
same entity group, and then we
don't have to worry about
cross-group transactions.
In our case, that turned
out to be fine.
We have to basically serialize
updates to this entity group
now, because there will be
contention for this entity
group as people are
making changes.
But that's going
to work for us.
So we're just going to do it.
If you're doing custom keys,
remember you're using a string
value, not an numeric value.
And so in our case, we pad with
zeros so that the strings
will be orderable and
ASCIIbetical order and
represent the actual
change orders.
This is how you'd
model with ndb.
No surprises here-- these
are just the fields.
I'm going to skip past this.
So the content-- we now have to
store the content somehow.
Couple things to think about
when modeling the content.
Remember, we've got this View
Request that needs to be
pretty fast.
We want the View Request
to come in, grab the
data, and serve it.
And we don't want to think too
hard about how that happens.
So as a general rule of thumb,
we decided to say, OK, this
View Request is coming in.
It has some information
it knows.
It should be able to get
everything it needs from the
datastore and then return
it to the user without
performing a query.
It's not strictly necessary,
but it's kind of a
nice rule of thumb.
So in this case, the View
Request knows the URL path.
And so that means at some point,
we're going to need
some datastore entity keyed off
of the URL path so it can
get that thing and then figure
out whatever else it needs to
do, as opposed to performing
some kind of a query.
One of the nice things about
this rule of thumb is that
it's really easy to imagine
what the Memcache layer is
going to look like.
If you're going to add in
caching, then you can just
cache these entities directly
into Memcache.
And then those same Gets can
occur on the Memcache just as
they would on the datastore.
But we also have to remember
that publishing needs to be
able to store new content
separately
from the live content.
So if it's just a single entity
keyed off of the URL
path, then when you're creating
another one of those,
that has to live side by side
with that before it gets
switched into the right thing.
So one idea-- again, there are
many ways of doing this.
But the one we went with was
to use a separate entity
called the Path entity keyed
off of the URL path.
And then that contains a pointer
to a Content entity.
So it looks something
like this.
One obvious disadvantage with
this is that the View Request
now has to make two datastore
calls, which you may not want.
Not only that, but it has
to make them in series.
It has to get the path
from the URL path.
And then it has to wait for that
to come back to know how
to get to the content object.
There are going to
be advantages
to this design later.
So this was actually something
that we lived with.
But that is a disadvantage if
you go do something like that.
So what about entity grouping?
Do we need to think about
transactionality for
anything like this?
So one idea, the one that
we used, is to have
one group per path.
And then that group contains
the path and
multiple content objects.
And that allows us to
set the content key.
We can change that pointer and
manipulate content objects in
a single transaction.
So it looks something
like this.
Here's your entity group.
It's pointing to the
old content.
New content comes in.
And then in a single
transaction, we can flip that
pointer and delete the old
content, all at the same time
to make sure that that's
guaranteed to work together in
a single transaction.
Here's the model for that.
Not a big deal.
So let's talk about the Apply
phase a little bit here.
This Commit comes in, and we've
got some work to do.
So what exactly happens?
Well, the client calls
the Commit method.
It's got a change ID
so we know what
change we're applying.
The server has two things to
do in response to this.
It has to update the change
record to say, yes, this is
now committed.
And it also has to kick off
some background work.
Now, if those two things happen
separately, there's
always a potential for one of
them to succeed and the other
one to fail.
So if you're updating the change
record first, then
maybe you update the change
record and the server now
believes that change is
committed successfully.
But it hasn't actually
successfully added a task to
the task queue.
Or if you did it the other way
around, then it could be
applying the change but not
realize that it's actually
committed it.
So what we can do here--
this is the justification for a
really important feature of
task queues.
You can add a task to a task
queue as part of a datastore
transaction.
So we are going to change
the Change record.
We're going to update the Change
record and set the
Apply Task in a transaction.
That means if the transaction
succeeds, both of those things
have happened.
If it fails, neither
of them have.
And then we can return an
error to the client.
And the client knows that
nothing is going to be changed
to the live website.
So the Apply Task-- and then if
it needs to, it can spawn
more tasks.
And then you've got all these
tasks on the website.
What guarantees that those tasks
are actually going to
complete successfully?
Well, the task queue does.
The task queue actually will
drive and retry those tasks
until they succeed.
So that's basically
our guarantee.
Once we have committed the
change and told the client
it's committed, the task is
already on the task queue.
And the task queue can figure
out how to make sure
everything works the way
it's supposed to.
One more thing we need
to talk about.
Say change one comes in and
then queues some tasks.
And change two comes in,
modifying the same file that
change one does.
And both of those getting queued
to the task queue.
The task queue does not
guarantee a first come, first
serve order when it's
executing tasks.
So it's possible for the apply
phase of change one to happen
after change two.
And that's going to violate
our expectation.
So what happens when these
things happen out of order?
Well, we take care of that
by ordering the changes.
This is why we ordered the
changes in a strict order.
Because now, we can store the
last change ID that's affected
a path with the path.
When change two comes in,
it updates a path.
And as part of that, it
says, I am change two.
Change two was the last
person to touch this.
So when change one comes in,
says, I also need to touch
this-- oh, wait, change two
has already been here.
I'm going to just return
success without
actually doing anything.
And then change two
continues to win.
It sticks.
In this way, the apply phase
only rolls forward in our
change history.
And so that's how we
ensure that these
things are going forward.
One minor design detail
we need to
account for is deletes.
Normally, you would think, oh,
well, if something comes in,
wants something deleted,
you can delete the
path and the content.
But in this case, we actually
need to remember which change
made that delete.
And so we're going to have
deletes represented in the
system as tombstones.
The content objects
can go away, but
the path object can't.
The path object is going to
stick around and say, yep, I
am deleted, and this is the
change that deleted me.
And that way, we can make
sure that deletes
stick in the same way.
So to summarize what
we've seen so far--
and that's basically all
the time we have.
So I'm just going to summarize
what we have.
We have a content management
system.
We've got this remote publishing
capability with
this general transactional
guarantee with eventual
consistency of application
of changes.
So when things go up, they're
as guaranteed as possible to
go onto the website.
We can have arbitrary change
sizes, so we can have many
thousands of files.
I want to put a little asterisk
next to that.
Because if you do implement
something like this, you're
going to find bottlenecks.
You're going to have various
places where change sizes are
going to be limited.
I'll give you one example from
what we've just seen.
We are creating these change
records in the datastore.
And they describe every
file in a project.
That change record is stored in
the datastore, which means
it has a 1 megabyte limit.
And so that's going
to be a limiting
factor on change size.
And if we get to the point where
we need changes larger
than that, we could engineer
around that.
We could figure out other ways
to represent changes in the
system, that sort of thing.
And you engineer around
any bottleneck.
But you usually do it-- you
wait until you hit the
bottleneck.
You wait until you need
something more before
building around it.
We are able to get easy
authenticated web services
using Google Cloud Endpoints.
We use the datastore for
transactional data storage.
We use the transactional
primitives to implement the
full protocol.
We used ndb for Python for
modeling the data.
And we used the task queue
for background tasks.
We didn't really talk about
caching that much, but you can
use Memcache as your
caching layer.
It's a service of App Engine.
But more importantly, ndb can
take care of it for you.
You don't have to think about
the caching interactions.
You just set a cache policy on
your datastore entities, and
ndb will figure out what goes in
the Memcache and how it can
manage all that stuff
quickly and easily.
We didn't say anything about
large object storage, but I
did mention the datastore
objects are
limited to one megabyte.
On the website, we do have
document objects
larger than a megabyte.
And so what do we
do with that?
Well, we put them in
cloud storage.
And the feature of
cloud storage--
also known as Blobstore--
makes this actually generally
invisible to both the content
developer and the end user.
I can handle that all
inside the protocol
implementation details.
And then the View
Request is just
another URL on your website.
And it just knows internally
to go to the Google Cloud
Storage to serve those things.
So you know the URL for
developers.google.com.
I did put together a small demo
of this protocol in a
little project in GitHub.
I actually do not have
the finished code
uploaded there yet.
But check back in a few days,
and I'll have the full thing
there, if you want to try
experimenting with that.
It is demo code.
I want to stress that.
There may be bugs and things.
Please feel free to
file bug reports.
I'll try to brush it up.
I actually do kind of
want a nice open
source version of this.
But there's that.
If you want to go to the book's
website and see more
information about the book,
that's the URL there.
I also have a Plus page
for the book.
And I can also be followed
on Google+.
One more thing about
the book--
I am doing a book signing
at 3:00 PM today out
in the cloud area.
We have a limited number of
free books to give away.
So if you want to show up at
3:00 PM, we'll see if we can
accommodate you.
I'd be just happy to meet you.
And I'd love to hear what you're
building on App Engine.
If you have any questions,
we have four
minutes left for questions.
So we have microphones.
You can come up to the
microphones and ask questions.
Otherwise, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDERSON: Hi, I'll take the
one in the back row first.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that you can have
a clock skew of up to
several minutes between various
App Engine instances.
DAN SANDERSON: Yeah, there
can be a clock skew.
I picked the term several
minutes kind of off
the top of my head.
It's sort of what I've
been told in the
distant past about it.
I think the main thing is that
there's really no guarantee of
synchronicity of the clocks
between them.
AUDIENCE: The question I really
had is how the logging
service deals with that.
DAN SANDERSON: That's
a good question.
I could look into
that for you.
I don't know if there's like
a separate service that's
actually logging that,
or if it's getting
the system time from--
AUDIENCE: Seems like kind
of an important--
DAN SANDERSON: No, exactly.
That is very interesting.
We can ask at the Cloud Booth
and I'll get a definitive
answer for you.
But I know a lot of the logs
are managed by a service.
So that can come up with
its own source of
time, but I'm not sure.
AUDIENCE: Great job.
This stuff is awesome.
But the question for you-- are
you using the App Engine
full-text search service?
DAN SANDERSON: That was
something I did not have time
to talk about.
Yeah, absolutely, if you're
building a content
management--
AUDIENCE: Is that going to
be in the sample code?
DAN SANDERSON: I would like to
add it to the sample code.
It's not in yet.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
So were there any challenges
that you found with using
full-text search API?
DAN SANDERSON: Not
really, actually.
It worked pretty much the way
you would expect it to.
They do a really good job of
synchronizing datastore
entities with the documents
in the search index.
We have a couple of basic ways
to get our documents into the
search service.
But it was pretty
straightforward kind of to the
terms of the search API.
AUDIENCE: As far as your
method for indexing the
documents, did you fire off a
task after the Commit phase to
add it to the search index?
Or did you do it as part of
the entire transaction?
Or did you do it separately
from the
transaction, from the Commit?
DAN SANDERSON: Well, one of
the nice things about the
Apply phase is you can
do basically an
arbitrary amount of work.
And it gets driven to completion
by the task queue.
So yeah, we do, at some point in
the Apply phase, manage the
updating of the search
indexes.
AUDIENCE: But I'm asking,
is it separate from that
transaction?
So in case search fails,
indexing fails, does that
block the transaction?
Or is it a completely
separate task?
DAN SANDERSON: You can define
those parameters yourself
based on how you
write the task.
If the API call fails for
whatever reason, you can
decide whether that's
fatal to the task
and needs to be retried.
AUDIENCE: Right, I was just
wondering what you guys did,
as far as--
did you decide to fail the task
or fail the transaction,
or just let it slide?
DAN SANDERSON: We have
a bunch of--
I don't know about the search
API specifically.
But there are a couple of cases
where we had to make
that call and say, OK, the task
is successful even if
that one thing didn't happen.
There are a couple of sort of
residual changes we make to
our data structures that
work kind of like that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
DAN SANDERSON: Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I'm back.
Did you just say that
the Blobstore is
really cloud storage?
DAN SANDERSON: They
are separate.
But the APIs are similar.
So that's why I didn't want to
make much of a distinction
between them.
The implementation we used
predates the cloud storage
that has the same API as the
Blobstore, so we use Blobstore
for the actual thing.
But you could easily use
cloud storage for that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
DAN SANDERSON: Anyone else?
OK, cool.
See you out there.
Thanks very much.